[Music]
I gotta be so rude of fools perfect song
for this in our new series reporters
notebook John Dickerson reflects on an
issue we've all been talking about a lot
lately civility in politics he recorded
his essay earlier this week he's in
Aspen Colorado as we think about
civility in politics the fourth of July
next week reminds us that our origins
were not civil the Tea Party was no tea
party the founders knew we would be in
civil and designed government to
accommodate that they also knew that
incivility needed a purpose the
Declaration of Independence was an
explanation of that original purpose
written because Jefferson wanted to show
a decent respect to the opinions of
mankind if they were going to be uncivil
the Declaration showed they still had
respect for the larger audience all of
mankind so the founders would ask of our
present incivility is it rooted in
anything larger or is it just impulse
point-scoring and power grabbing she's a
low IQ individual when the president is
uncivil is it for a higher purpose or is
it confirmation that an impulsive
president must be checked when Maxine
Waters rails can we hear a universal
value' or is she just rallying the mob
this test can be applied to our chance
at rallies and our behavior at
restaurants too
the fourth of July is not just a
celebration but an assignment
Jefferson asked that the annual return
of this day forever refresh our
recollections of these rights and an
undiminished devotion to them listening
to the founders might sound quaint while
we're blowtorching each other on Twitter
but even during America's most difficult
time Abraham Lincoln built the
Gettysburg Address around those values
in the Declaration of Independence the
founders knew that we would sometimes
treat each other like dogs but because
we were an example to the world that we
would all strive to do better refreshing
that faith is why Wednesday should be
more than just another day off very good
point you know didn't your mom tell you
guys when you were little two wrongs
don't make a right
yes and all this clamor and all this
vitriol on both sides you're right if
there are some people who will say as we
said earlier this week that you know dr.
King said you know you can't fight hate
with hate others though will say look
this is a if you are continuing to give
space to people who are intolerant then
ultimately tolerance will lose because
the intolerant will continue to grow I'm
a firm believer that a lot of it still
comes from the top and and that you know
becomes something that the country sees
and whether they're conscious or
subconsciously starting to act that way
I think we're seeing some of it again
yeah I think there's an extra burden
forget politics yeah right extra burden
for our leaders and they ignited so
right we haven't forget politics yeah
and they can learn from our leaders like
Thomas Jefferson and Abraham Lincoln and
John Dickerson there is a hinge on being
there is a better way nice John
Dickerson right